Lorient était à l'honneur ce week-end à
l'espace Albert Camus de Maurepas des
initiations aux percussions aux
dégustation de spécialités orientales
comme le thé à la menthe les visiteurs
ont découvert toute la richesse de
Constantinople mais aussi le slam cette
poésie ou les mots permettent d'exprimer
ce que l'on vit au quotidien comme le
fait la marraine de l'atelier Tata
Milouda c'est John maroquet arrivait en
France sans savoir lire et écrire je
n'ai pas honte de le dire
je suis fier de le dire de chanter
pour dégager ma souffrance de mon passé
pendant que les grands écoutent les vers
de Tata Milouda les petits se font
maquiller fabriquent leurs propres sacs
ou peignent avec les doigts aux côtés
des animateurs de la ville c'est très
bien ça dresseur plus souvent d'ailleurs
soit les comptes et les activités c'est
nickel quoi la culture était aussi à
l'honneur les lectures de contes captent
l'attention des plus jeunes et on
raconte il y avait un roi
ce roi vivait dans un château et les
portes ce château étaient toujours
ouverte des histoires de visière aux
initiations de percussion comme le
djembé les jeunes ont pu traverser
l'univers de Lorient en quelques heures
en matière de percussion orientale donc
chaque petit groupe passe une demi-heure
donc il y a vraiment une initiation de
frappe frapper et puis peut-être un
petit rythme il y a quand même un gros
goût une grosse motivation sur la
musique pour ses ados de ma repas la
fête orientale c'est conclue par un
concert hip-hop métissé